Silver State Schools Credit Union the
sponsors of the segment is all about
giving the gift of financial success to
their clients I spoke to president and
CEO Scott a Arcos to find out how
welcome back to the show Scott it's so
good to see you last time we had you on
we were talking about Silver State
Schools Credit Union certificate account
promotion you've got to tell me is this
promotion still available it sure is
Mercedes I'm glad you asked so during
the holidays there's a saying that comes
to mind giving is better than receiving
so why not gift our future selves the
gift of financial success at Silver
State Schools Credit Union we try to
provide products and services that
actually help our members achieve that
financial success and so uh by giving
yourself the gift of savings as holiday
with a 12-month certificate of uh
deposit account that'll earn
3.35 and that's only on a 12 month and
so and all you need is a minimum deposit
of 500
um and so this uh offers available for
existing deposits with silver state
Schools Credit Union or by transferring
deposits from other financial
institutions and that's a little bit
different from what we've done in the
past uh sometimes we just ask for new
money from uh from different
institutions but this time we're
actually allowing our members to do
existing deposits as well if they want
to so there are certain restrictions
that do apply uh but you can get
complete uh details
um online at silverstatecu.com
um or by visiting any one of the 10
branch locations we have in the valley
another thing you you take care of the
kids and you allow them to be creative
and when we talked about this a few
months ago you guys are having the Happy
Times Calendar contest it was artwork
submission time did you guys finally
select the artwork we did we did and I'm
so glad you you asked about that as well
we actually had over 3 000 artwork
submissions uh this year from students
in grades K through 12 and the best one
from each grade was selected and this is
our 38 37th annual uh um Happy Times
Calendar for 2023
and uh so the artwork depict really what
the idea here is that the artwork
depicts each of the students idea of
what a happy time is and it's showcased
uh really for the first time um at this
uh award and the winners are honored
um at this uh at the reason the Happy
Times Awards uh ceremony when are these
gonna be available the Happy Time
calendars are now available and members
can visit any one of our 10 branch
locations in the Las Vegas Valley as
well as Henderson to pick up their
complimentary
um copy and and we do that while
supplies last and and really due to the
popularity our members they love these
things and uh and and there's really a
limited print run anyone in the
community though can get a copy
um if or if members would like
additional copies that can be purchased
for just two dollars per calendar which
is uh really a great deal and not only
that a Mercedes but the proceeds from
the calendar sales actually go directly
to the people uh over profit Foundation
or the pop Foundation which is our
charitable arm of Silver State Schools
Credit Union and so that goes back into
the education system really to support
the kids again
thank you again to Silver State Schools
Credit Union for sponsoring this segment
become a member today you can call them
at
702-733-8820 or get more information at
silverstatecu.com